で また宣伝の通りに言ってます
チャンスとピンチっていうのは
お互いにチャンスはピンチになって
ピンチはチャンスになるという話ですね
で 回転するんですかと
本当に で これ 宣伝文句
ピンチの後にチャンスあり
チャンスの後にピンチありとも言いますが
今の自分の状況について
てっかくにやめなければ
チャンスもピンチも意外に見分けられないものです
ちょっとお待ちください
この問題について学びましょう
このポイント これでいきなりわからないことが出てくるんです
仏教って難しいんですよ
存在 とは 存在とは生と滅の波なのです
存在っていうのは現れては消えていく波なんです
因との原因と縁 条件ですね
により この波も一定に起こるのではなく
変わっていく 例えば世の中は生と滅
生と滅の波といえば 波っていうのはすごい行儀よく起こるものでしょうに
しかし 世の中の波ってそうでもない
因と縁によって 波の形はまたごちゃごちゃ変わったりする
波といえば 穏やかである一定の周波数で波が押すのは普通なんですけど
これが周波数がもう変わったり
強弱になったり むちゃくちゃなんですね
それは因果法則ということで
で 生まれた赤ちゃんが必ず確実に老人になって死ぬということはありえませんね
普通の波だったら 赤ちゃんが生まれて
どんどん大きくなって
年取って老人になって死ぬっていうの
でもそうはうまくいかないんですよ
普通の波 そうなんですけど
また横からいろんな因縁
条件がつなげるんだから
もうどうなるかわからない波になっちゃうんです
世の中は 固定した定めがないが
物事は偶然的に起こらない
法則がある これっていうのはもう言葉で理解するしかないんです
もう結構もうそのままもう理解するしかない言葉
単語なんですけど 人生に
生命に 宇宙に固定した定めっていうのはない
例えば 神様を信仰する方々は
もうの一部はね すべて固定的に
神はもう過去現在未来すべて知ってるんだから
決まって定めているというね
そんないう方々も一部がいる
神様は信仰する世界ではね
また一部は神様は作ったのは作ったんだけど
それから人間の自由意識で自分の考え方は変えなくちゃいけないというふうなことを言っている人もいる
ですから それに照らして言いますけど
固定した定めがないんだけど
因果法則によってな 世界は変化していく
だから次にどうなるかということはなかなか言い難いんですよ
言い難いんだけど 明日偶然何か起こるということもありえないんです
明日どうなっても 因果法則の結果なんです
問題は 今の今日の自分が考えている因果関係に何か突然足したり
なくなったりする可能性もあります
チャンスの後 何が起こるっていう問題ですね
だから宣伝文句でチャンスの後はピンチやと
ピンチの後ならチャンスやという一般論なんですけど
ではチャンスの次どうなるのかということは勉強してみましょう
世はラブ得 アラート損
あやそう不明誉 やそう名誉
忍耐 避難 破産さ 賞賛 苦困
楽 ドゥッカ 苦の波であると仏教が説かれる
それは仏教でも いつでも世の中
そういう波で変わっていくんだと
一つだけはダメです ありえないんです
得だけとかはできない
楽だけも成り立ちません
苦もある 人に求めて褒めてもらうだけでもなくて
非難される時もある 自分の欲望で美味しいと
美味しいところだけ取ろうとしても
これは無理な話です 持ちなき怠です
だから世の中の波で まあ美味しいところだけ
得だけ 楽だけ 称賛だけ取ろうと思ったっても
これってありえないんです
この八種の波は このいわゆる個人を中心にして語られるんですね
受ける側の状況 ということは
私個人がこの世の中で生きている場合は
損もあって得もあって
楽もあって苦みあるという
私に それで一人一人の個人に
そういう世界なんですよ
我々はある世界 社会という海の中にいるんですよ
この社会から損はするわ
得はするわ 褒めてもらうわ
非難されるわ そういう 8種類の波にスーッとぶつからなくちゃいけないんですよ
自分が いわゆる受ける側
それで受ける側と与える側って 2つ成り立つのです
私が受ける側 与える側というのは
世間が与える側なんですね
受ける側は個で 与える側は世間です
世間にはある特定の個人を狙って称賛する気持ちも
非難する気持ちもないんですよ
だって世間から見れば
世界があの人を狙って攻撃しましょう
あの人を狙って称賛する
そんなのないんですよ
意外と無関心で冷静でクールです
世界は 世界はクールなんですけど
世界の中に生きている私にとっては全然クールじゃないんですよ
称賛されると気分がいいんだけど
非難されるとはものすごいもう嫌なんでしょうしね
得するときはもうすごい気持ちいいんだけど
損するときは自分がもうクールじゃないんですよ
すごいもう混乱するんです
しかし 私一人で混乱したり興奮したりするんだけど
私を混乱させたり興奮させたりする世界がクールです
それ よくも考えておいた方がいいことですよ
良いか悪いかは個人の判断ですよ
それで世界はごく一般的にクールで冷静で変化しているだけで
私が勝手に もう世界に対して
宇宙に対して 全生命体に対して
私個人があれは嫌だ これだったらいいやとかね
自分が判断するだけ まあ例えば今
石油の値段がすごく高い
それで石油を買う日本は
これでは困ると 状況が悪いんだと
と勝手に判断する そこで石油は産業の国で第2番目のソ連は
あ よかったと いつも石油の高騰はもう誰もわからないんだけど
もう何の理由もなく もういい加減な世界だから経済
というのはね 何の価格性も具体性もないんだだからただ理由もなく値段が高騰するだけ
それで受ける側にとって
それはもう幸福でとるか不幸でとるかということなんです
したがって 世の波はチャンスかピンチかにするのは私個人ではないでしょうか
と 世の中の波を これはチャンスにするかピンチにするかというのは
私個人の勝手なんです
勝手と言ったっても勝手でもないんだけど
私個人なんです もう石油を買わなくちゃいけない国々にとってはもうピンチですけど
もう勝手に思っているとも言えませんだけど
まあ実際にピンチなんです
石油を産業する国々にとってはもうすごいチャンスですね
それで言いたいのは 石油値段高騰っていうのは別にどうったことないことなんです
すごい冷静でクールなんです
その現象だけは 受ける側にとってはそうじゃないんです
自我と実体がない存在
それでそのポイント終わっちゃったんです
世界には実体が 世には実体がないから
絶えず変化して変わっていく
世の中っていうのは全然実体がない
ずっと 例えば石油高騰したでも
これ誰がやっているのかというと
誰でもないでしょうに
なのにそうなるんです
しかし 見事に見習い忘れることは
自分も世の一部であることです
それで私たちはよく忘れるんですよ
私も別に特定なものじゃなくて
ただ世の中の一部なんですよ
だから海に例えれば 海のね
水の一滴なんですよ これ
水の一滴は偉そうに自分だけと思っちゃうと話にならないんですよ
でも 私一人一人では 宇宙存在という海の中のたった一滴なのに
自分特別ですよと思っちゃうんですね
そこは間違いなんです
これ忘れるんですよ 変わらない自分という立場で世を見て
世の中で生きている 決してうまくいかない
だから自分がいると思っちゃうと
自分というのは変わらないんですよ
で 変わらない自分が世の中に生きているんだから
世の中はずーっと変わっていくんだからね
こちらは振ったり蹴ったり状態なんですよ
海の中で特別な存在として
ある水の一滴が生きようとするんだから
ひどい目に遭うんです
だから変わらない自分という立場で世の中を見てはならないんで
自分も変わりますよと
例えば もう地震が起きて家が破れ壊れちゃうと
みんな避難して困るでしょ
悩むでしょうね 大変だ
苦しいなっていうのは当たり前
どうったことはない しかし
悩むのは変わらない自分という概念があるんだからなんですよ
家が壊れた 私も同時に変わりましたと
今避難所にいるんだと
自分も変わってますよ
そうすると いいとも悪いと言えなくなっちゃうんですよ
まあ今こんな状態やと
それではいい  1年前はあんな状態で
今日はこんな状態で 明日は別な状態やと
だから一緒に変わることであるにも関わらず
それを認めないだけ 一緒に変わってくださいと頼んでないんで
私は あんた方も世の中の波に乗って変わってくださいと
くだらんことを頼まなくたって
どうせ変わっているんだから
これは避けられませんよ
ただ なんでこれ認めないのかと
例えば 私はもうすごく年取って
髪の毛も白くなっちゃって
全部見えませんね だからもう丁寧に剃るんです
で 昨日見たらもうこの辺全部白いんです
で まあだからといって私はもう 20ぐらいやとかね
30代ぐらいやとかね
そんな気になってもね
意味がないんですよ もう変わってるんだから
とっくに ある子供に言われた覚えがあるんですね
そんなこと言ったって
あんた年でしょうと 大体自分のこういうような子供たちは平気でそういうことを言うんですよ
そういうことで 波の衝突っていうことが起きるんですよ
本当は衝突おかしいんですよ
海が自分で波が作っているだけで
波と波は絶対衝突しません
衝突する？しませんよ
でも私たちの場合は起こるんですよ
これって不自然ですよ
海では波と波が衝突はないのに
なんでこの存在の中であるのかというと
個人は心を持っているので
希望により世についてある特定の波を期待して待ち構えている
そこで個人には心があるでしょうに
心で妄想したり考えたりするでしょうね
それで我々は心の中である特定の波を期待するんです
それは希望ということなんです
世の中こうなってほしいなと
例えばラーメン屋さんを開業したら
まあ毎日百ぐらいのお客さんが来てほしいと
そうすると何とかあの借金は払えますよとか
自分勝手にある波を作って待ち構えているんです
しかし 現れた波が違うものである時
対応できず衝突する これがピンチなんです
なので ラーメン屋さんが計算して借金して作ったんだからね
うーん まあ一日百人ぐらいお客さんが来れば
まあ 2万  1万ぐらい浮きますよと
これで 1ヶ月間で 30万
30万払えると 見事な計算なんですけど
それはもう自分だけの作った希望の波なんですよ
でも 開業はしたんだけど
初めの日は友達が来てくれたんだから
50人で 次の日はもうやっと 4人とか 5人とかね
そうなるんですよ そうするともう衝突
もうどうしようもなくなっちゃう
ピンチってのはそういうことです
それ ラーメン屋さんピンチでしょ
明らかに 実際は世間の波によって上がったり下がったりして流されてきている
結局どうなるのかというと
世間の波によって上がったり下がったりだけなんです
100人のお客さんが期待していても
自分が来るお客様によって左右されなくちゃいけないんですよ
もう 100人以上が来ると
もう得をしてよかったよかったと 10
人とか 5人になったところで
もう今日はもう赤字で
もうどうしようもないんだと
材料の値段も戻らないんだと
電気代と労働費とか それを置いといたとしてもということになる
だから結局世界が操っているんです
が 衝突は苦難を生み出す
それで流されているんだったら楽でしょうに
そうじゃないでしょう
すごい苦しいんです 自分がある波を期待する
期待しても絶対それはありえないんです
世間の波に流されるしかないんです
しかし 流されても苦しいんです
そういうことで 山の後
谷はありませんでしたということになるんです
チャンスとピンチの これどう読むかわかりませんだけど
一応総合的に変わるというね
思考は一般論で 必ずしもその通りになるとは限らないんです
チャンスの後 ピンチ ピンチの後
チャンスっていうのは
そんな丁寧な波であったらね
苦労ないでしょうに 必ずしも山の後谷っていうことじゃないと
ピンチになったら悩んだり
落ち込んだり 無理をしたりするから
無知な態度をとってしまうのは普通の人のやり方ですよ
ピンチになっちゃうと
もう悩むわ もう震えるわ
落ち込んだりするわ 怒るわ
無理なことをするわ それってのは普通のやり方なんです
ピンチはどこまでもピンチだけ引き起こすんです
そうすると ピンチからピンチへということになっちゃう
みんな言ってる あんな甘い話じゃないんですよ
実際は これが本当の世界なんです
山あり谷ありじゃないんです
チャンスの時も 舞い上がったり
高慢になったり 無知な態度をとる
それでうまくいくとえらく舞い上がって
じゃあこのラーメン屋さんうまくいってるんじゃもう 1軒店を開くそうとか
えらいことしちゃうんですよ
舞い上がったりして これで失敗するんです
だから素早く大ピンチを呼ぶんです
ということは 方程式はピンチだったらどこまでピンチからピンチ行くかわからない
たまたまチャンスだったら
間もないうちにピンチ
ピンチ ピンチでまた行くんです
ほとんどピンチの方ばっかしです
それで山も谷も見える人がいるんです
無常の自分 自我的でない自分には
世の中の波は冷静に見えるのです
私たちは無常で 私も無常で
自我がないんだと思うということで
ずっと瞬間瞬間変化するものだということで
世の中を見ていると 見事にこの変化が見えてくるんです
あ この波は徳の波だ この波はもうその波やとかね
物理学的なら固定したものに波を取れるが
心理の世界では逆です
まあ物理学的にも波を理解するためには固定したもので対照してみるんですよ
まあ一応海 海に波があるってわかるのは海岸にいる時なんですよ
海のど真ん中にいるとそんなに気にしない
そういう物理的に言えば
固定したものは固定しないものを測ったりする
でも心理学の世界 心理の世界ではね
違うんです 自分もずっと変化するんだなとわかっていると
たとえ何かものを見た瞬間に
あ それによってこれぐらい変化するんだとわかっていると
今楽しいんだけど あちらに行ったら当然楽しくなくなっちゃうんだぞとかね
で あるところですごく楽しく舞い上がっていて
あ 私はかなり明るい人間やと
もう怖いものを知らそうと思ったら間違いなんですよ
そうじゃない 私はこの環境ってすごく明るく楽しいんだけど
あの環境に行ったらこうなる
この環境に行ったらこうなるという自分というのは定めてないんだぞとわかってる人にのみ環境は見えるんです
自我の自分があると 特定の波を期待して他の波を無視する
それで我々よくやることは
私はこういうことを期待していると世界に対して期待するんですよ
そこで自分考えた波が来るまでじっと待ってるんだけど
ずっと新しい波が生まれるのに見えなくなっちゃうんです
あの特定の波しか見えなくなっちゃうんです
それはあの研究の世界でよくわかりますよ
研究する人々はある特定のものをしか研究しないでしょう
その場合はいろんな情報を調べるんだけど
自分に必要なデータしか目に入らないんです
例えば図書館に行っても
自分が研究する分野に関わる本に本しか目に入りません
巨大な図書館に行っても
そんなもんで 人間がある特定の波を作っちゃうと
世の中の波を無視するんですよ
これってすっごく危ないんです
はい それで このチャンスはピンチ
ピンチはチャンスになるということは
実は成り立たないという結論なんです
本当の状況を見ると ピンチからピンチへ
ピンチへピンチへ行って
やがて世間がいい波になると
なんとかなるだけなんです
私たちはわざわざピンチをピンチにするんです
そこでいい波になってチャンスになったところでも
無知だから 調子に乗るんだから
感情的になるんだから
あのチャンスをピンチに変えてしまっちゃうのが正しいやり方なんです
というか 正しいではなくて
世の中のやり方なんです
そこで次のセクションに入ります
うん